we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p um this is a very interesting
voicemail
this voicemail raises an interesting
question i had not thought about let's
take a listen to it hi david
uh i was just wondering um if
biden takes the if biden is elected what
is the likelihood
that uh clarence thomas resigned in the
lame duck session
thanks okay
that's a very very interesting question
if indeed
joe biden defeats donald trump
um would clarence thomas
maybe immediately retire from the
supreme court
allowing trump to push through
a supreme court pick younger than thomas
who will be on the court for longer
i don't think it's particularly likely
because clarence thomas is relatively
young he's 72 and
i don't know that clarence thomas has
any interest in leaving the court
so it's not something i would expect but
i wonder
i do wonder if joe biden does win
will there be people on the right
putting pressure on clarence thomas or
putting pressure on trump
to call up clarence thomas to say listen
let's put
in a 45 year old and establish
ingrain absent an expansion of the court
a conservative supreme court for a
really really long time
it's a scary thought and i wish i could
say they could never do it
they during a lame duck they could never
do it because they said in 2016 you
don't do it during the last year
guys they just did it during the last
week with amy coney barrett so i think
they would be able to do it
i don't know that clarence thomas
is seen as an urgent person to replace
with someone younger he's 72
ruth bader ginsburg was far older um
and although i believe antonin scalia
was only 74 when he suddenly died
i i don't expect that to happen but it's
a very intere you're thinking about this
the right way which is
no matter what what last middle finger
fuse is trump going to be able to throw
whenever it is that he's finally done
whether it's now
or whether it's four years from now okay
tomorrow night i will be live streaming
election results
we are going to have all the coverage
for you we will be
looking at network calls we will be
doing our own map we will have a likely
and projected map
producer pat put together a fantastic
chart of bellwether counties counties
that
with almost no exceptions the winner of
those counties almost always wins the
states
excellent data we have all of it okay
and i will be starting with the first
results
just short of 7 p.m eastern time uh
tomorrow evening
just short just shy of 4 p.m eastern
pacific
i will be on youtube twitch and facebook
go to youtube now and click the set
reminder button
on our youtube stream the more people
that click that button
the more interest you are signaling to
youtube's algorithm
about our coverage and thus the more
people
that will be suggested our coverage by
youtube
very exciting stuff on today's bonus
show
donald trump changed his election night
plan he had a party planned at his hotel
instead he's going to be at the white
house we will talk about it on the bonus
show
texas republicans tried to stop drive
through voting and tried to get a
hundred and some odd thousand votes
thrown out
they have failed to do it that's good
but they're continuing to fight
that's not good and we are now realizing
that about 100 million people
are going to be voting early last
election only about 135 million people
voted total
100 million people will have voted
already
before election day incredible we will
talk about
what those numbers look like in terms of
where they're coming from and whether we
can read anything into them about the
future of this election
my argument is even if you can let's not
let's just get out and vote
all of those stories on today's bonus
show
two ways to access the bonus show become
a member
at joinpacman.com or become a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow i will
see you then
and then tomorrow and then on our live
election night coverage see you then